ただいま
[音楽]
上詰で帰って来れば横根ジャズ技術はですまあ twitter とかで知っている方
をしていると思うんですけども私はじめシャツを1週間ほど会が入ってました
越冬
2006日の旅砂糖で何してたかっていうのはまあまあお楽しみに
またどこかでおセラせしますまじねあのね200名から度ねーぜっ
ブービー精神心身ともにもポカーンでしたからねほんとにびっくりしたんですけどまぁ
そう分いいよぴぃカンタロスはっはー
わけねーだろは僕ちょっと旅をすると必ずトラブルが起きるって言うあるんでしょそう
いうのが別途かつて後6年前に京都に旅行に行った時には財布をなくしました見つかっ
たけど元気が全文抜き取られていました
卒業旅行イタリアの旅イタリアが詐欺師にあって3万円くらい分取られましたそして
今回
二泊三日のうちの一泊の時ホテルに行こう止まったんですよええ
太ってホテルとかでスツケス.いっ鈴木椅子を置いて山に出かけますか
行った時に何かその治安がいいとも言えない場所だったねほ手荷物を受け押すと分かっ
たねスーツケースにも鍵をかけようかなとんで効果切ってるんでしょこのスーツです3
桁勝って
カチャカチャ飾っちゃって鍵かけるところなんですよねこれでいつもない僕の誕生日の
兄5用
これ言っていいのか駄目だって僕が何かこう特殊な3つの数字を送って売って鍵かけれ
ました
ってこうやってもちろんどこかでクザン火山であってよし
これでて開けるんだろうなぁと思って負け買って21安打で3つの僕の設定パンポン
ポンってやったら開かなくなってしまいました
終わった
さて俺のための終わりでしたなんで僕もその旅の途中上から一切スーツケースの中身を
使うことができませんでした今日何時につけて持ち歩いてるだけでもう本当に元に
立てるものが本当これぐらいしかなくてほどを積んでなんですよ
もうほんと開かないぢゃあかないっすよ見た目のニーズ4出かけだと思うんですけど
開かなくてずれてのから314とか違うティッチも違う
間違えてどっかに松江ブロックしちゃったのかって説は競ってあるんだと思ったんです
けどちょっと開かないんども225 p あマジで開かないするそんなつにするかな
いやオオイイでしょなんかも
旅行超入れるためしたんですけど猫に安協てが無くてこれウムの確か登録者何人記念の
時にいただいたものでもう34年くらいすごい大切に使っているものなんですけど
開かないなぁ
助けて代車労組は組タイルや6だなぁかないわこれ
終わった冬の居るた皆さん機で何回もやったんですよ快適ではおかないとねこれ中身
どうしたらいいのって話だよ
goo
でもね幸いなことに僕この説明で結構も壊れてましてロッカーがって僕もつの穴行く
ですよねもう完璧はここから吹くだけこれ取り立てる可能性がですよ私はセーター
セーターゲット
よかった逆にもスーツケースが壊れてて良かったところでありますね
これ全部取り稼ぐぞねええ
[音楽]
えっ
me
うーん
ここまでの良さ000から999まで全部試しと解除できる可能性があるんですけど
時間がもったいないえっと
のような鍵あげる時には6500円くらいかかるらしいです
いやーやだしまってないよだってあげてくれるちょっと個入ったじゃうべきキュヴェ
んってことに強まってません僕待てないという意だ
僕よく東京に行くことが多くて3年間か
本当にずっと愛用させていただきましたこのスーツケースてもう服が見えるくらい壊れ
ちゃってるんで
そういうことでしょ今まで本当にありがとう
[音楽]
me
高知わーここはずしかないんですよコースしかないなんてこんな塗布スゴイダイズな
もの入ってるんですよこれは気に新しいスーツケースを買おうと思いますまたねこれ
壊れてなかったら話は別だと思うんですけどもうけっこうこれあないというのもの落ち
ちゃったりしてたのでパン年間よく守った
どうします
[音楽]
床はてる方がった最高なんですけども
これも使う好きでやるしかねーな moon
ん
ほ
bar みくるさん力でば千葉ジェッツ
開けばいいパターンですけど
グループ e
持っています
ここにパターンを通して中で通してうってことでいい
来いっても続きでば切ってください辺だ
[音楽]
me
それだからだその超つをエヴァってこんなに簡単に取れていいものなのか
気合でいけるもんだろ持っている人からポットに撮ったらもう cd 切るんじゃない
か説がある
戸枝ブッフェで待ってももの
o バック
[音楽]
を
服しか入ってねーちょっと埋まって行った普通に開きました
まずで茜だと思ったんだけどドライバー人って浸からず管を受けることができましたよ
があっああああああっ
あっあってこれでねちょっとこれでねこれ
デマって言って肩腰が痛くなっちゃったよ
[拍手]
[音楽]
ありがとうございました